convicted criminals now just openly
mocking democrats soft on crime policies
a baltimore man who pled guilty to arson
after setting his girlfriend's house on
fire while people were inside now saying
he was surprised to be set free after
less than six months in jail thanks to a
sweet plea deal from baltimore's top
prosecutor marilyn mosby
i was just charged with 18 different
counts that was dropped to 10 and then
it was dropped to one
when i shouldn't be out right now that
tells anybody that oh i can go shoot
somebody or i could go attempt to shoot
somebody and i'll be completely fine it
would empower me because i would be like
okay
this man just shot somebody
just blew his head off
and he is out walking free oh i can do
anything i want
a spokesman for marilyn mosby's office
defending it
oh and speaking of mosby by the way she
was just indicted by a federal grand
jury on two counts of perjury and two
counts of making false loan applications
so i mean maybe she is one of those da's
who literally likes the criminal more
than the victim but you know i'll go to
you geraldo i mean this is a a defendant
18 counts to 10 to 1 to a misdemeanor
three of those counts were attempted
murder what say you it's horrifying and
it's so stupid judge and i just have to
read this baltimore state attorney
marilyn mosby just in the last two hours
a rising star thrust into the national
spotlight after the 2015 police custody
death of freddie gray i covered that in
baltimore indicted by a federal grand
jury two counts of perjury making false
loan applications so you got crooks on
both sides of the aisle in the baltimore
county
prosecutor's office it is these plea
deals are stupid why are they so stupid
because
when you when a someone goes to ponder
whether or not someone should get early
release they look at what they pled to
or were convicted of which is generally
speaking where it ends up not where the
process begins as this thug says he was
indicted on 18 counts 18 counts pled
down to 10 pled down to one
sentenced to one so it's ridiculous the
fact that
an attempted murderer is out after six
months is so reflective of the situation
in these big democratic-run cities where
the district attorneys are running amok
now their pro their uh priority is to
empty the jails letting people like take
another look at that guy with them with
the he's wearing a mask as well with the
shoulder pad what is that what is that
that if you saw that person on the
street would you would you stay on the
same side of the sidewalk as that person
how do you know i mean
first of all the problem and i'll go to
jesse with this jesse the problem is
that marilyn mosby is one of those da's
elected with soros monies and geraldo is
right i followed the freddie gray case
she comes out with the autopsy report
and within 24 hours indicts everybody
that who are ultimately acquitted
because she's incompetent she's not only
incompetent now she's charged with
federal offenses
what should happen to her and you know
why she she took out a loan for 50 grand
and then 40 grand fake loans covered
relief fake loans and then you know what
she did she bought two vacation homes
where in florida so these liberals love
to bash florida on television next thing
you know they're they're going on
spending sprees in longboat key and in
miami
it's a what a bunch of hypocrites
geraldo i don't know what he was working
i think it might have been a work outfit
by the way but i don't know but here's
my theory don't jump down my throat
judge it's just a theory i think the d.a
maybe thought this was just a crime of
passion the guy said this was a romeo
and juliet situation he was high his
buddies put him up to it if i can't have
her nobody can and he wandered over
there with the gasoline in the match
maybe
maybe that's the only reason i can think
of that they gave this guy a wrist slap
for three attempted murder charges maybe
they just thought it was crazy
ex-boyfriend stuff you know what crazy
ex-boyfriend stuff attempted murder is
criminal it's evil and there's a big
difference between a suicide you want to
kill yourself whatever you don't kill
somebody else
so but dana you wanted to say something
before but i want to read you what the
judge said who's just as bad the judge
says
when he vacates a warrant because
there's another charge pending somewhere
else against this guy the judge says be
careful and stay safe to this defendant
when it's a people in his path who need
to be careful and stay safe well the
other day alvin bragg was a new d.a here
in manhattan said he was shocked to hear
that his policies were controversial and
he was offended that people like us
would question it but then don't listen
to us listen to them
i mean the criminals are saying please
stop helping us
that is totally bizarre and under
marilyn mosby baltimore has become
baltha-less
it is a terrible situation there
one more thing about new york last night
there were two carjackings yeah one
right by my apartment another one way
downtown
and in the one by my apartment the guy
who did the carjacking the suspect then
used the car
to go after another car like rammed
another car and then kind of tried to go
after a police officer but nobody was
hurt wow so under as i read the brag
memo that would be a misdemeanor right
yes yes absolutely all right greg wrap
it up and talk about how safe we are in
new york well first there obviously
there is more to this story uh
this guy is mad because he has no place
to live he burned down his ex's house
and they released him from prison and
he's like what are you doing i had three
hots and a cot
now i gotta walk around i don't even
have a girlfriend anymore everybody
hates me but here's you know what
criminals are smart enough to realize
that if you destroy society with enough
progressive reforms there is no society
left for the criminal to prey upon every
parasite needs to keep the host alive so
here you have a
criminal that's going whoa slow down
democrats i still need to steal i still
need to loot i need to still have some
businesses there that's that's the real
story okay thank you for that hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else